The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOSH TENENBAUM: We're going to--
I'm just going to give a
bunch of examples of things
that we in our field have done.
Most of them are things that
I've played some role in.
Maybe it was a thesis
project of a student.
But they're meant to be
representative of a broader
set of things that many
people have been working
on developing this toolkit.
And we're going to start from
the beginning in a sense-- just
some very simple
things that we did
to try to look at ways in
which probabilistic, generative
models can inform people's
basic cognitive processes.
And then build up to
more interestingly kinds
of symbolically structured
models, hierarchical models,
and ultimately to these
probabilistic programs
for common sense.
So when I say a lot of
people have been doing this,
I mean here's just a small
number of these people.
Every year or two, I try
to update this slide.
But it's very much
historically dated with people
that I knew when I was
in grad school basically.
There's a lot of
really great work
by younger people who
maybe their names haven't
appeared on this slide.
So those dot dot dots
are extremely serious.
And a lot of the best stuff
is not included on here.
But in the last
couple of decades,
across basically all
the different areas
of cognitive science
that cover basically
all the different things
that cognition does,
there's been great progress
building serious mathematical--
and what we could call reverse
engineering models in the sense
that they are quantitative
models of human cognition,
but they are phrased in
the terms of engineering,
the same things you would
use to build a robot
to do these things,
at least in principle.
And it's been
developing this toolkit
of probabalistic
generative models.
I want to start
off by telling you
a little bit about some
work that I did together
with Tom Griffiths.
So Tom is now a senior
faculty member at Berkeley,
one of the leaders
in this field--
as well as a leading person
in machine learning, actually.
One of the great
things that he's done
is to take inspiration
from human learning
and develop fundamentally new
kinds of probabilistic models,
in non-parametric
Bayes in particular,
inspired by human learning.
But when Tom was a grad
student, we worked together.
He was my first student.
We're almost the same age.
So at this point, we're
more like senior colleagues
than student advisor.
But I'll tell you
about some work
we did back when
he was a student,
and I was just starting off.
And we were both together
trying to tackle this problem
and trying to see, OK, what are
the prospects for understanding
even very basic cognitive
intuitions, like senses
of similarity or the most
basic kinds of causal discovery
intuitions like we were
talking about before,
using some kind of idea
of probabilistic inference
in a generative model?
And at the time-- remember
in the introduction
I was talking about how
there's been this back
and forth discourse over the
decades of people saying, yeah,
rah rah, statistics,
and, statistics,
those are trivial
and uninteresting?
And at the time we started
to do this, at least
in cognitive
psychology, the idea
that cognition could
be seen as some kind
of sophisticated
statistical inference
was very much not
a popular idea.
But we thought that it
was fundamentally right
in some ways.
And it was at the time--
again, this was work we were
doing in the early 2000s
when it was very clear in
machine learning and AI
already how transformative
these ideas were
in building intelligent
machines or starting
to build intelligent machines.
So it seemed clear to
us that at least it
was a good hypothesis worth
exploring and taking much more
seriously than psychologists
had much before that.
That this also could
describe basic aspects
of human thinking.
So I'll give you a couple
examples of what we did here.
Here's a simple kind of causal
inference from coincidences,
much like what you saw
going on in the video game.
There's no time in this.
It's really mostly just space,
or maybe a little bit of time.
The motivation was not a
video game, but imagine--
to put a real world
context on it--
what's sometimes called cancer
clusters or rare disease
clusters.
You can read about these
often in the newspaper, where
somebody has seen some evidence
suggestive of some maybe
hidden environmental cause--
maybe it's a toxic chemical
leak or something--
that seems to be responsible
for-- or maybe they
don't have a cause.
They just see a
suspicious coincidence
of some very rare disease, a
few cases that seem surprisingly
clustered in space and time.
So for example, let's say this
is one square mile of a city.
And each dot represents one case
of some very rare disease that
occurred in the span of a year.
And you look at this.
And you might think
that, well, it
doesn't look like those dots are
completely, uniformly, randomly
distributed over there.
Maybe there's some
weird thing going on
in the upper left or
northwest corner--
some who knows what--
making people sick.
So let me just ask you.
On a scale of 0 to 10,
where 10 means you're sure
there's some kind
of thing going on
and some special cause
in some part of this map.
And 0 means no, you're quite
sure there's nothing going on.
It's just random.
What do you say?
To what extent does this give
evidence for some hidden cause?
So give me a number
between 0 and 10.
AUDIENCE: 5.
JOSH TENENBAUM: OK, great.
5, 2, 7.
I heard a few examples
of each of those.
Perfect.
That's exactly what people do.
You could do the same
thing on Mechanical Turk,
and get 10 times as much
data, and pay a lot more.
It would be the same.
I'll show you the
data in a second.
But here's the
model that we built.
So again, this model
is a very simple kind
of generative model
of a hidden cause
that various people
in statistics
have worked with for a while.
We're basically modeling a
hidden cause as a mixture.
Or I mean it's a
generative model,
so we have to model
the whole data.
When we say there's
a hidden cause,
we don't necessarily mean that
everything is caused by this.
It's just that the data
we see in this picture
is a mixture of whatever the
normal random thing going on is
plus possibly some spatially
localized cause that
has some unknown
position, unknown extent.
Maybe it's a very big region.
And some unknown
intensity-- maybe
it's causing a lot of
cases or not that many.
The hypothesis space maybe
is best visualized like this.
Each of these squares is
a different hypothesis
of a mixture density
or a mixture model--
which is a mixture of just
whatever the normal uniform
process is that causes a disease
unrelated to space and then
some kind of just Gaussian bump,
which can vary in location,
size, and intensity, that
is the possible hidden cause
of some of these cases.
And what the model
that we propose says
is that your sense of
this spatial coincidence--
like when you look at a pattern
of dots really and you see,
oh, that looks like there's a
hidden cluster there somewhere.
It's basically you're trying to
see whether something like one
of those things on the right is
going on as opposed to the null
hypothesis of just
pure randomness.
So we take this log
likelihood ratio,
or log probability,
where we're comparing
the probability of the
data under the hypothesis
that there's some
interesting hidden cause, one
of the things on the right,
versus the alternative
hypothesis that
it's just random,
which is just the simple,
completely uniform density.
And what makes this a little
bit interesting computationally
is that there's an infinite
number of these possibilities
on the right.
There's an infinite number
of different locations
and sizes and intensities
of the Gaussian.
And you have to integrate
over all of them.
So again, there's not
going to be a whole lot
of mathematical details here.
But you can read
about this stuff
if you want to read these
papers that we had here.
But for those of you who
are familiar with this,
with working with
latent variable models,
effectively what
you're doing is just
integrating either analytically
or in a simulation over all
the possible models
and sort of trying
to compute on average how
much does the evidence support
something like what you see on
the right, one of those cluster
possibilities, versus
just uniform density.
And now what I'm showing
you is that model
compared to people's
judgments on an experiment.
So in this experiment,
we showed people patterns
like the one you just saw.
The one you saw
is this one here.
But in the different
stimuli, we varied parameters
that we thought
would be relevant.
So we varied how many
points were there total,
how strong the cluster was in
various ways, whether it was
very tightly
clustered or very big,
the relative number of points
in the cluster versus not.
So what you can see
here, for example,
is it's a very similar
kind of geometry,
except here this is a
sort of biggish cluster.
And then we're making basically
there's four points that look
clustered and two that aren't.
And in these cases, we
just make the four points
more tightly clustered.
Here, what we're
doing is we're going
from having no points that look
clustered to having almost all
of the points looking
clustered and just varying
the ratio of clustered points
to non-clustered points.
Here, we're just changing
the overall number.
So notice that this one is
basically the same as this one.
So again, at both
of these, we've
got four clustered points and
two seemingly non-clustered
ones.
And here we just scale
up in set-- or scale
up from four to two,
to eight and four.
And here we scale it
down to two and one,
and various other manipulations.
And what you can
see is that they
have various systematic
effects on people's judgments.
So what I'm calling
the data there
is the average of
about 150 people
who did the same
judgment you did--
0 to 10.
What you can see is the one
I gave you was this one here.
And the average judgment
was almost exactly five.
And if you look at
the variance, it
looks just like
what you saw here.
Some people say two or three.
Some people say seven.
I chose one that was
right in the middle.
The interesting thing
is that, while you maybe
felt like you were
guessing-- and if you just
listened to what
everyone else was saying,
maybe it sounds like we're just
shouting out random numbers--
that's not what you're doing.
On that one, it looks
like it, because it's
right on the threshold.
But if you look over all
these different patterns, what
you see is that sometimes
people give much higher numbers
than others.
Sometimes people give much
lower number than others.
And the details,
that variation, both
within these different
manipulations we did
and across them,
are almost perfectly
captured by this very simple
probabilistic generative
model for a latent cause.
So the model here is-- this is
the predictions that model I
showed you is
making, where again,
basically, a high
bar means there's
strong evidence in favor of the
hidden latent cause hypothesis.
Some, one, or more--
some cluster-- that low
bar means strong evidence
for the alternative hypothesis.
The scale is a bit arbitrary.
And it's a log
probability ratio scale.
So I'm not going to
comment on the scale.
But importantly, it's the same
scale across all of these.
So a big difference is,
it's the same big difference
in both cases.
And I don't think this
is fairly good evidence
that this model is
capturing your sense
of spatial coincidence
and showing that it's not
just random or arbitrary,
but it's actually
a very rational measure of
how much evidence there is
in the data for a hidden cause.
Here's the same
model now applied
to a different data
set that we actually
collected a few
years before, which
just varies the same
kinds of parameters,
but has a lot more points.
And the same model works
in those cases, too.
The differences are
a little more subtle
with these more points.
So I'll give you one other
example of this sort of thing.
Like the one I just
showed you, we're
taking a fairly simple
statistical model.
This one, as you'll see,
isn't even really causal.
This one at least, that
I showed you, is causal.
The advantage of
this other one is
that it's both a kind of
textbook statistics example,
it's one where people do
something more interesting
than what's in the textbook.
Although you can extend the
textbook analysis to make
it look like what people do.
And unlike in this
case here, you
can actually measure
the empirical statistic.
You can go out, and instead
of just like positing,
here's a simple model of what
a latent environmental cause
would be like, you can
actually go and measure
all the relevant
probability distributions
and compare people not
just with a notional model,
but with what, in
some stronger sense,
is the rational
thing to do, if you
were doing some kind of
intuitive Bayesian inference.
So these are, again
stuff that Tom Griffiths
did with me, in an in and
then after grad school.
We asked people to
make the following kind
of everyday prediction.
So we said, suppose you
read about a movie that's
made $60 million to date.
How much money will
it make in total?
Or you see that
something's been baking
in the oven for 34 minutes.
How long until it's ready?
You meet someone
who's 78 years old.
How long will they live?
Your friend quotes to you from
line 17 of his favorite poem.
How long is the poem?
Or you meet a US congressman
who has served for 11 years.
How long will he serve in total?
So in each of
these cases, you're
encountering some
phenomenon or event
in the world with some
unknown total duration.
We'll call that t, total.
And all we know is that
t, total, is somewhere
between zero and infinity.
We might have a prior on it,
as you'll see in a second.
But we don't know very much
about this particular t,
total except you get one
example, one piece of data,
some t, which we'll just
assume is just randomly sampled
between zero and t, total.
So all we know is that
whatever these things are,
it's something randomly chosen,
less than the total extent
or duration of these events.
And now we can ask,
what can you guess
about the total extent
or duration from that one
observation?
Or in mathematical terms,
there is some unknown interval
from zero up to
some maximal value.
You can put a prior on
what that interval is.
And you have to guess the
interval from one sampled point
sampled randomly within it.
It's also very similar--
and another reason
we studied this-- to
the problem of learning
a concept from one example.
When you're learning what
horses are from one example,
or when you're learning what
that piece of rock climbing
question is-- what's a cam--
from one example, or what's
a tufa from one example.
You can think,
there's some region
in the space of all possible
objects or something,
or some set out there.
And you get one or
a few sample points,
and you have to figure out
the extent of the region.
It's basically the same kind
of problem, mathematically.
But what's cool
about this is we can
measure the priors for these
different classes of events
and compare people with an
optimal Bayesian inference.
And you see something
kind of striking.
So here's, on the top--
I'm showing two different
kinds of data here.
On the top are just empirical
statistics of events
you can measure in the world;
nothing behavioral, nothing
about cognition.
On the bottom, I'm showing
some behavioral data
and comparing it with
model predictions that
are based on the statistics
that are measured on top.
So what we have
in each column is
one of these classes of events,
like movie grosses in dollars.
You can get this data from iMDB,
the Internet Movie Database.
You can see that most movies
make $100 million or less.
There's sort of a power law.
But a few movies make hundreds,
or even many hundreds,
maybe a billion dollars
even, these days.
Similarly with poems, they
have a power law distribution
of length.
So most poems are pretty short.
They fit on a page or less.
But there are some
epic poems, or
some multi-page-- many,
many hundreds of lines.
And they fall off
with a long tail.
Lifespans, movie runtimes
are kind of unimodal, almost
Gaussian-- not exactly.
Those red curves,
histograms' bars,
show the empirical
statistics that we
measured from public data.
And the red curves
show just the best fit
of a simple parametric model,
like a Gaussian or a power law
distribution that
I'm mentioning.
House of representatives-- how
long people serve in the House
has this kind of gamma,
or particular gamma
called an Erlang shape
with a little bit
of an incumbent effect.
Cake baking times-- so
remember we asked how long
is this cake going to bake for.
They don't have any simple
parametric form when you go in
and look at cookbooks.
But you see, there's
something systematic there.
There's a lot of things
that are supposed
to bake for exactly an hour.
There are some which have
a smaller, or a shorter,
but broad mode.
And then there's a few epic
90-minute cakes out there.
So that's all the
empirical statistics.
Now what you're seeing on
the bottom is people's--
well, on the y-axis,
the vertical axis,
you have the average--
it's a median--
of a bunch of human predictions
for the total extent
of any one of these
things, like your guess
of the total length
of a poem given that,
basically, there
is a line 17 in it.
And on the x-axis, what you're
seeing is that one data point,
the one value of t,
which is, all you know
is that it's somewhere
between zero and t, total.
So different groups
of subjects were
given five different values.
So you see five black dots,
which correspond to what
five different
subgroups of subjects
said for each of these
possible t values.
And then the black
and red curves
are the model fit,
which comes from taking
a certain kind of Bayesian
optimal prediction, where
the prior is what's
specified on the top-- that's
the prior on t, total.
The likelihood is a sort
of uniform random density.
So it's just saying t is just a
uniform random sample from zero
up to t, total.
You put those together
to compute a posterior.
And then you-- the particular
estimator we're using
is what's called the
posterior median.
So we're looking at the
median of the exterior
and comparing that with a
median of human subjects.
And what you can see is that
it's almost a perfect fit.
And it doesn't really
matter whether you
take the red curve, which is
what comes from approximating
the prior with one of these
simple parametric models,
or the black one,
which comes from just
taking the empirical histogram.
Although, for the
cake baking times,
you really can only go
for the empirical one.
Because there is no
simple parametric one.
That's why you just see a
jagged black line there.
But it's interesting that
it's almost a perfect fit.
There are a couple--
just like somebody
asked in Demis's talk--
there's one or two cases we
found where this model doesn't
work, sometimes dramatically,
and sometimes a little bit.
And they're all interesting.
But I have time
to talk about it.
That's one of the things
I decided to skip.
If you'd like to talk about
it, I'm happy to do that.
But most of the time, in most
of the cases we've studied,
these are representative.
And I think, again, all
of the failure cases
are quite interesting ones.
That point to, this is
one of the many things
we need to go beyond.
But the interesting
thing isn't just
that the curves fit
the data, but the fact
that the actual shape is
different in each case.
Depending on the prior of this
different classes of events,
you get a fundamentally
different, or qualitatively
different, prediction function.
Sometimes it's linear.
Sometimes it's non-linear.
Sometimes it has
some weird shape.
And really, quite
surprisingly to us,
people seem to be
sensitive to that.
So they seem to predict in ways
that are reflective of not only
the optimal Bayesian
thing to do,
but the optimal Bayesian thing
to do from the optimal prior,
from the correct prior.
And I certainly don't want
to suggest that people always
do this.
But it was very
interesting to us
that for just a bunch of
everyday events, and really,
the places where this
analysis works best
are ones, again, where we think
people actually might plausibly
have good reasons to have
the relevant experiences
with these everyday
events, they seem
to be sensitive to both the
statistics in the sense of just
what's going on in
the world and doing
the right statistical
prediction.
So that's what we did.
10 years ago or so,
that was like the state
of the art for us.
And then we wanted
to know, well, OK,
can we take these sorts
of ideas and scale them up
to some actually interesting
cognitive problems,
like say, for example, learning
words for object categories.
And we did some of that.
I'll show you a
little bit of that
before showing you what I
think was missing there.
I mean, in a lot of ways,
this is a harder problem.
I mean, it's very
similar, as I said.
It's basically like, there's
just like the problem I just
showed you, where there
was an unknown total extent
or duration, and you got
one random sample from it,
here there is some un--
imagine the space of
all possible objects--
could be a manifold or
described by a bunch of knobs.
I mean, these are all generated
from some computer program.
If these were real,
biological things,
they would be generated
from DNA or whatever it is.
But there's some huge, maybe
interestingly structured, space
of all possible objects.
And within that space is some
subset, some region or subset,
somehow described that
is the set of tufas.
And somehow you're able to
grasp that subset, more or less,
if you get its boundaries,
to be able to say yes or no
as you did at the
beginning of the lecture
from just, in this case, a
few points-- three points--
randomly sampled from
somewhere in that region.
It would work just as well
if I showed you one of them,
basically.
So in some sense,
it's the same problem.
But it's much harder,
because here, the space
was this one dimensional thing.
It was just a number.
Whereas here, we
don't know what's
the dimensionality of
the space of objects.
We don't know how to
describe the regions.
Here we knew how to
They were just intervals
with a lower bound at zero
and an upper bound at
some unknown thing.
And the hypothesis space
of possible regions
was just all the possible upper
bounds of this event duration.
Here we don't know how
to describe this space.
We don't know how to
describe the regions that
correspond to object concepts.
We don't know how to put a
price on those hypotheses.
But in some work that
we did-- in particular,
some work that I did
with Fei Xu, who is also
a professor at Berkeley.
We were colleagues and
friends in graduate school.
We sort of did what
we could at the time.
So we made some guesses about
what that hypothesis space--
what that space might be like,
what the hypothesis space might
be like, how to put some
priors, and so, on there.
Used exactly the
same likelihood,
which was just this very simple
idea that the observed examples
are a uniform random draw
from some subset of the world.
And you have to figure
out what that subset is.
And we were able to
make some progress.
So what we did was we said,
well, like in biology,
perhaps-- and if you saw-- how
many people saw Surya Ganguli's
lecture yesterday morning?
Cool.
I sort of tailored this for
assuming that you probably
had seen that.
Because there's a lot of
similarities, or parallels,
which is neat.
And it's, again, part of
engaging on generative models
and neural networks.
As you saw him do, you'll
get my version of this.
So also, like he
mentioned, there
are actual processes in the
world which generate objects--
something like this.
We know about evolution--
produces basically
tree-structured groups,
which we call species, or genus,
or something like that, or just
taxa, or something.
There's groups of
organisms that have
a common evolutionary descent.
That's the way a biologist
might describe it.
And we know, these days,
a lot about the mechanisms
that produce that.
Even going back
100 or 200 years,
say, to Darwin,
we knew something
about the mechanisms
that produced it,
even if we didn't know
the genetic details, ideas
of something like mutation,
variation, natural selection
as a kind of
mechanistic account,
about right up there
with Newton and forces.
But anyway, scientists
can describe some process
that generates trees.
And maybe people
have some intuition,
just like people seem
to have some intuitions
about these statistics
of everyday events,
maybe they have some
intuitions, somehow,
about the causal processes
in the world, which
give rise to groups and
groups and subgroups.
And they can use that to
set up a hypothesis space.
And the way we
went about this is,
we have no idea how to describe
people's internal mental models
of these things, but
you can do some simple--
there are simple ways
to get this picture
by just basically asking
people to judge similarity
and doing hierarchical
clustering.
So this is a tree that we built
up by just asking people--
getting some subjective
similarity metric
and then doing hierarchical
clustering, which we thought
could roughly approximate
maybe the internal hierarchy
that our mental
models impose on this.
Were you raising your
hand or just-- no.
OK.
Cool.
We ultimately found
this dissatisfying,
because we don't really
know what the features are.
We don't really know if
this is the right tree
or how people built it up.
But it actually
worked pretty well,
in the sense that we
could build up this tree.
We could then assume that
the hypotheses for concepts
just corresponded to
branches of the tree.
And then you could--
again, to put it
just intuitively,
the way you do this learning
from one or a few examples,
let's say that you see
those few tufas over there.
You're basically asking,
which branch of the tree
do I think-- those are randomly
drawn from some internal branch
of the tree, some subtree.
Which subtree is it?
And intuitively, if you see
those things and you say,
well, they are randomly
drawn from some branch,
maybe it's the one
that I've circled.
That sounds like a better bet,
for example, than this one
here, or maybe this
one, which would
include one of these
things, but not the others.
So that's probably unlikely.
And it's probably a
better bet than, say,
this branch, or this branch, or
these ones, which are logically
compatible, but somehow
it would have been sort
of a suspicious coincidence.
If the set of tufas had
really been this branch here,
or this one here, then it would
have been quite a coincidence
that the first three
examples you saw
were all clustered over
there in one corner.
And what we showed was
that, that kind of model,
where that suspicious
coincidence came out
from the same kinds
of things I've just
been showing you for the
causal clustering example,
and for the interval thing,
it's the same Bayesian math.
But now with this
tree-structured hypothesis
space, that was actually--
did a pretty good job
of capturing people's judgments.
We gave people one or a few
examples of these concepts
that, the examples could be
more narrowly or broadly spread,
just like you saw in
the clustering thing,
but just sort of less extensive.
We did this with adults.
We did this with kids.
And I won't really go
into any of the details.
but If you're interested,
check out these various Xu
and Tenenbaum papers.
That's the main one there.
And you know, the
model kind of worked.
But ultimately, we
found it dissatisfying.
Because we couldn't
really explain--
we didn't really know what
the hypothesis space was.
We didn't really know how people
were building up this tree.
And so we did a few things.
We-- meaning I with
some other people--
turned to other problems where
we had a better idea, maybe,
of the feature space and
the hypothesis space,
but the same kind of ideas
could be explored and developed.
And then ultimately-- and I'll
show you this maybe before
lunch, or maybe after lunch--
we went back and tackled the
problem of learning concepts
from examples with other cases
where we could get a better
handle on really knowing what
the representations that people
were using were, and also where
we could compare with machines
in much more compelling
apples and oranges ways.
In some sense here, there's
no machine, as far as I know,
that can solve this problem
as well as our model.
On the other hand,
that's, again, it's
just very much like
the issue that came up
when we were talking about--
I guess maybe it was
with you, Tyler--
when we were talking about the
deep learning-- or with you,
Leo--
the deep reinforcement network.
A machine that's looking
at this just as pixels
is missing so much
of what we bring
to it, which is,
we see these things
as three-dimensional objects.
And just like the
cam in rock climbing,
or any of those
other examples I gave
before, I think that's
essential to the abilities
that people are doing.
The generative model
we build, this tree
is based not on pixels, or
even on ConvNet features,
but on a sense of the
three-dimensional objects,
its parts, and their
relations to each other.
And so, fundamentally, until
we know how to perceive objects
better, this is not going to
be comparable between humans
and machines on equal terms.
But I'll show you
a little bit later
some still pretty quite
interesting, but simpler,
visual concepts that you can
still learn and generalize
from one example, but where they
are comparable in equal terms.
But first I want to tell you
a little bit about these--
yet another cognitive
judgment, which
like the word learning,
or concept learning cases,
involved generalizing
from a few examples.
They also involve
using prior knowledge.
But they're ones
where maybe we have
some way of capturing people's
prior knowledge by using
the right combination
of statistical inference
on some kind of symbolically
structured bottle.
So you can already see, as--
I mean, just sort of to
show the narrative here.
The examples I was
giving here, this
doesn't require any
symbolic structure.
All that stuff I was
talking at the beginning,
about how we have to combine
statistical inference,
sophisticated
with sophisticated
symbolic representations,
you don't need any of that here.
All the representations
could just
be counting up numbers or
using simple probability
distributions that
statisticians have
worked with for over 100 years.
Once we start to go
here, now we have
to define a model with
some interesting structure,
like a branching tree
structure, and so on.
And as you'll see,
we can quickly
get to lots more
interesting causal,
compositionally-structured
generative models
in similar kinds of tasks.
And in particular,
we were looking for--
for a few years, we
were very interested
in these property
induction tasks.
So this was-- it
happened to be--
I mean, I think this
was a coincidence.
Or maybe we were both influenced
by Susan Carey, actually.
So the work that Surya talked
about, that he was trying
to explain as a
theoretician-- remember,
Surya and Andrew
Saxe, they were trying
to give the theory of
these neural network
models that Jay
McClelland and Tim
Rogers had built
in the early 2000s,
around the same time we
were doing this work.
And they were inspired by
some of Susan Carey's work
on children's intuitive
biology, as well as
other people out there
in cognitive psychology--
for example, Lance
Rips, and Smith, Madine.
Many, many cognitive
psychologists
studied things like this--
Dan Osherson.
They often talked about this as
a kind of inductive reasoning,
or property induction,
where the idea was--
so it might look different from
the task I've given you before,
but actually, it's
deeply related.
The task was often presented
to people like an argument
with premises and
a conclusion, kind
of like a traditional deductive
syllogism, like all men are
mortal, Socrates is a man,
therefore Socrates is mortal.
But these are
inductive in that there
is no-- you can't conclude
with deductive certainty
the conclusion follows
from the premises
or is falsified by the
premise, but rather you just
make a good guess.
The statements above the line
provide some, more or less,
good or bad evidence
for the statement
below the line being true.
These studies were
often done with-- they
could be done with just sort of
familiar biological properties,
like having hairy legs or
being bigger than a breadbox.
I mean, it's also-- it's very
much the same kind of thing
that Tom Mitchell was talking
about, as you'll start to see.
There's another reason why
I wanted to cover this.
We worked on these
things because we
wanted to be able to engage
with the same kinds of things
that people like Jay
McClelland and Tom Mitchell
were thinking about, coming
from different perspectives.
Remember, Tom
Mitchell showed you
his way of classifying brain
representations of semantics
with matrices of objects and
20-question-like features that
included things like is
it hairy, or is it alive,
or does it eggs, or is
it bigger than a car,
or bigger than a
breadbox, or whatever.
Any one of these things--
basically, we're getting
at the same thing.
Here there's just what's--
often these
experiments with humans
were done with so-called
blank predicates, something
that sounded vaguely biological,
but was basically made up,
or that most people
wouldn't know much about.
Does anyone know anything
about T9 hormones?
I hope so, because I made it up.
But some of them were
just done with things
that were real, but not
known to most people.
So if I tell you that
gorillas and seals both have
T9 hormones, you might think
it's sort of, fairly plausible
that horses have T9 hormones,
maybe more so than if I
hadn't told you anything.
Maybe you think that
argument is more
plausible than the one
on the right; given
that gorillas and seals have
T9 or hormones, that anteaters
have hormones.
So maybe you think
horses are somehow
more similar to gorillas and
seals than anteaters are.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe a little bit.
If I made that bees--
gorillas and seals
have T9 on hormones.
Does that make you think
it's likely that bees have
T9 hormones, or pine trees?
The farther the
conclusion category
gets from the premises, the
less plausible it seems.
Maybe the one on the lower right
also seems not very plausible,
or not as plausible.
Because if I tell
you that gorillas
have T9 hormones, chimps,
monkeys, and baboons
all have T9 on
hormones, maybe you
think that it's only
primates or something.
So they're not a
very-- it's, again,
one of these
typicality-suspicious
coincidence businesses.
So again, you can
think of it as-- you
can do these experiments
in various ways.
I won't really go
through the details,
but it basically
involves giving people
a bunch of different sets
of examples, just like--
I mean, in some sense,
the important thing to get
is that abstractly it has
the same character of all
the other tasks you've seen.
You're giving people one or
a few examples, which we're
going to treat as random
draws from some concept,
or some region in
some larger space.
In this case, the examples
are the different premise
categories, like
gorillas and seals
are examples of the concept
of having T9 hormones.
Or gorillas, chimps,
monkeys, and baboons
are an example of a concept.
We're going to put a
prior on possible extents
of that concept, and then
ask what kind of inferences
people make from that
prior, to figure out
what other things
are in that concept.
So are horses in
that same concept?
Or are anteaters?
Or are horses in it more or
less, depending on the examples
you give?
And what's the
nature of that prior?
And what's good
about this is that,
kind of like the everyday
prediction task--
the lines of the poems, or
the movie grosses, or the cake
baking-- we can actually
sort of go out and measure
some features that are
plausibly relevant,
to set up a plausibly
relevant prior,
unlike the interesting
object cases.
But like the interesting
object cases,
there are some interesting
hierarchical and other kinds
of causal compositional
structures
that people seem
to be using that we
can capture in our models.
So here, again, the kinds of
experiments-- these features
were generated many years ago
by Osherson and colleagues.
But it's very similar
to the 20 questions game
that Tom Mitchell used.
And I don't remember
if Surya talked
about where these
features came from,
that he talked a lot about a
matrix of objects and features.
I don't know if he talked
about where they come from.
But actually, psychologists
spent a while coming up
with ways to get
people to just tell you
a bunch of features of animals.
This is, again, it's meant
to capture the knowledge
that maybe a kid would get
from maybe plausibly reading
books and going to the zoo.
We know that elephants are gray.
They're hairless.
They have tough skin.
They're big.
They have a bulbous body shape.
They have long legs.
These are all mostly
relative to other animals.
They have a tail.
They have tusks.
They might be smelly,
compared to other animals--
smellier than average is
sort of what that means.
They walk, as opposed to fly.
They're slow, as
opposed to fast.
They're strong, as
opposed to weak.
It's that kind of business.
So basically what that gives
you is this big matrix.
Again, the same kind
of thing that you
saw in Surya's talk,
the same kind of thing
that Tom Mitchell
is using to help
classify things, the
same kind of thing
that basically everybody
in machine learning
uses-- a matrix of data
with objects, maybe as rows,
and features, or
attributes, as columns.
And the problem here is--
the problem of
learning is to say--
the problem of learning and
generalizing from one example
is to take a new property,
which is a new concept, which
is like a new
column here, to get
one or a few examples of that
concept, which is basically
just filling in one or a
few entries in that column,
and figure out how to fill
in the others, to decide,
do you or don't you have
that property, somehow
building knowledge
that you can generalize
from your prior
experience, which
could be captured by, say,
all the other features
that you know about objects.
So that's the way
that you might set up
this problem, which again, looks
like a lot of other problems
of, say, semi-supervised
learning or sparse matrix
completion.
It's a problem in which
we can, or at least
we thought we could,
compare humans
and many different
algorithms, and even theory,
like from Surya's talk.
And that seemed very
appealing to us.
What we thought, though,
that people were doing,
which is maybe a little
different than what--
or somewhat different-- well,
quite different than what Jay
McClelland thought
people were doing--
maybe a little bit more like
what Susan Carey or some
of the earlier psychologists
thought people were doing--
was something like this.
That the way we
solve this problem,
the way we bridged from our
prior experience to new things
we wanted to learn was
not, say, by just computing
the second order of
statistics and correlations,
and compressing that through
some bottleneck hidden layer,
but by building a
more interesting
structured probabilistic
model that was, in some form,
causal--
in some form-- in some
form, compositional
and hierarchical--
something kind of like this.
And this is a good example of a
hierarchical generative model.
There's three layers
of structure here.
The bottom layer is
the observable layer.
So the arrows in these
generative models point down,
often, usually, where the thing
on the bottom is the thing
you observe, the data
of your experience.
And then the stuff above it
are various levels of structure
that your mind is
positing to explain it.
So here we have two
levels of structure.
The level above this is sort
of this tree in your head.
The idea-- it's like a certain
kind of graph structure,
where the objects, or the
species, are the leaf nodes.
And there's some internal
nodes corresponding,
maybe to higher level taxa,
or groups, or something.
You might have words for
these, too, like mammal,
or primate, or animal.
And the idea is that
there's some kind
of probabilistic model
that you can describe,
maybe even a causal one on top
of that symbolic structure,
that tree, that produces the
data that's more directly
observable, the
observable features,
including the things
you've only sparsely
observed and want to fill in.
And then you might also have
higher levels of structure.
Like if you want to
explain, how did you
learn that tree in
the first place,
maybe it's because you have
some kind of generative model
for that generative model.
So here I'm just using
words to describe it,
but I'll show you some
other stuff in a--
or I'll show you something
more formal a little bit later.
But you could say,
well, maybe the way
I figure out that there's
a tree structure is
by having a hypothesis--
the way I figure
out that there's
that particular tree-structured
graphical model of this domain
is by having the more
general hypothesis
that there is some latent
hierarchy of species.
And I just have to figure
out which one it is.
So you could formulate this
as a hierarchical inference
by saying that
what we're calling
the form, the form
of the model, it's
like a hypothesis space of
models, which are themselves
hypothesis spaces of possible
observed patterns of feature
correlation.
And that, that higher
level knowledge,
puts some kind of a generative
model on these graph
structures, where each
graph structure then
puts a generative model on
the data you can observe.
And then you could
have even higher levels
of this sort of thing.
And then learning could
go on at any or all levels
of this hierarchy, higher
than the level of experience.
So just to show you a little
bit about how this kind of thing
works, what we're calling
the probability of the data
given the structure is actually
exactly the same, really,
as the model that Surya
and Andrew Saxe used.
The difference is that
we were suggesting--
may be right, may be wrong--
that something like
this generative model
was actually in your head.
Surya presented a very
simple abstraction
of evolutionary branching
process, a kind of diffusion
over the tree, where properties
could turn on or off.
And we built basically
that same kind of model.
And we said, maybe you
have something in your head
as a model of, again, the
distribution of properties,
or features, or attributes over
the leaf nodes of the tree.
So if you have this kind
of statistical model.
If you think that there's
something like a tree
structure, and properties are
produced over the leaf nodes
by some kind of switching,
on-and-off, mutation-like
process, then you can do
something like in this picture
here.
You can take an observe a set
of features in that matrix
and learn the best tree.
You can figure out that
thing I'm showing on the top,
that structure, which is,
in some sense, the best
guess of a tree structure-- a
latent tree structure-- which
if you then define some
kind of diffusion mutation
process over that tree, would
produce with high probability
distributions of features
like those shown there.
If I gave you a
very different tree
it would produce other
patterns of correlation.
And it's just like
Surya said, it
can be all captured by the
second order statistics
of feature correlations.
The nice thing about
this is that now this
also gives a distribution
on new properties.
So if I observe--
because each column is
conditionally independent
given that model.
Each column is an
independent sample
from that generative model.
And the idea is if I
observe a new property,
and I want to say, well, which
other things have this, well,
I can make a guess on using
that probabilistic model.
I can say, all
right, given that I
know the value of this
function over the tree,
this stochastic process,
at some points, what
do I think the most likely
values are at other points?
And basically, what you get is,
again, like in the diffusion
process, a kind of
similarity-based generalization
with a tree-structured metric,
that nearby points in the tree
are likely to have
the same value.
So in particular, things that
are near to, say, species one
and nine are probably going
to have the same property,
and others maybe less so.
And you build that model.
And it's really quite
striking how much
it matches people's intuitions.
So now you're seeing the kinds
of plots I was showing you
before, where--
all my data plots
look like this.
Whenever I'm showing the
scatterplot, by default,
the y-axis is the average of
a bunch of people's judgments,
and the x-axis is the model
predictions on the same units
or scale.
And each of these
scatterplots is
from a different
experiment-- not done
by us, done by other people,
like Osherson and Smith
from a couple of decades ago.
But they all sort of have
the same kind of form,
where each dot is a
different set of examples,
or a different argument.
And what typically varied
within an experiment--
you vary the examples.
And you fix constant
the conclusion category.
And you see, basically,
how much evidential support
to different sets of
two or three examples
gives to a certain conclusion.
And it's really, again,
quite striking that--
sometimes in a more
categorical way,
sometimes in a more graded
way-- but basically,
people's average
judgments here just
line up quite well with the
sort of Bayesian inference
on this tree-structured
generative model.
These are just examples of
the kinds of stimuli here.
Now, we can compare.
One of the reasons
why we were interested
in this was to compare, again,
many different approaches.
So here I'm going to show
you a comparison with just
a variant of our approach.
It's the same kind of
hierarchical Bayesian model,
but now the structure
isn't a tree,
it's a low-dimensional
Euclidean space.
You can define the same kinds
of proximity smoothness thing.
I mean, again, it's more a
standard in machine learning.
It's related to
Gaussian processes.
It's much more like
neural networks.
You could think of this as
kind of like a Bayesian version
of a bottleneck hidden
layer with two dimensions,
or a small number of dimensions.
The pictures that Surya showed
you were all higher dimensions
than two dimensions
in the latent space,
or the hidden variable
space, of the neural network,
the hidden layer space.
But when he compress it
down to two dimensions,
it looks pretty good.
So it's the same kind of idea.
Now what you're saying
is you're going to find,
not the best tree that
explains all these features,
but the best
two-dimensional space.
Maybe it looks like this.
Where, again, the
probabilistic model
says that things which are
relatively-- things that
are closer in this
two-dimensional space
are more likely to have
the same feature value.
So you're basically explaining
all the pairwise feature
correlations by
distance in this space.
It's similar.
Importantly it's not as
causal and compositional.
The tree models something about,
possibly, the causal processes
of how organisms come to be.
If I told you that,
oh, there's this--
that I told you about a
subspecies, like whatever--
what's a good example--
different breeds of dogs.
Or I told you that, oh, well,
there's not just wolves,
but there's the gray-tailed
wolf and the red-tailed wolf.
Red-tailed wolf?
I don't know.
Again, they're probably
similar, but they might--
one red-tailed wolf,
whatever that is, more
similar to another
red-tailed wolf,
probably has more
features in common
than with a gray-tailed
wolf, and probably more
to the gray-tailed
wolf than to a dog.
The nice thing about a tree is
I can tell you these things,
and you can, in your mind--
maybe you'll never forget that
there's a red-tailed wolf.
There isn't.
I just made it up.
But if you ever find
yourself thinking
about red-tailed wolves and
whether their properties are
more or less similar to each
other than to gray-tailed
wolves, or less so
to dogs, or so on,
it's because I just
said some things,
and you grew out your
tree in your mind.
That's a lot harder to do
in a low-dimensional space.
And it turns out
that, that model also
fits this data less well.
So here I'm just showing
two of those experiments.
Some of them are well
fit by that model,
but others are less well fit.
Now, that's not to
say that they wouldn't
be good for other things.
So we also did some experiments.
This was experiments
that we did.
Oh, actually, I forgot to
say, really importantly,
this was all worked done
by Charles Kemp, who's
now a professor at CMU.
And it was part of the stuff
that he did in his PhD thesis.
So we were interested in this
as a way, not to study trees,
but to study a range of
different kinds of structures.
And it is true, going back,
I guess, to the question
you asked, this is what
I was referring to about
low-dimensional manifolds.
There are some kinds of
knowledge representations
we have which might have
a low-dimensional spatial
structure, in particular,
like mental maps of the world.
So our intuitive models of the
Earth's surface, and things
which might be distributed
over the Earth's surface
spatially, a two-dimensional
map is probably
a good one for that.
So here we considered a
similar kind of concept
learning from a few examples
task, where we said--
but now we put it like this.
We said, suppose
that a certain kind
of Native American
artifact has been
found in sites near city x.
How likely is it also to be
found in sites near city y?
Or we could say sites near
city x and y, how about city z.
And we told people that
different Native American
tribes maybe had-- some lived
in a very small area, some
lived in a very big area.
Some lived in one place,
some another place.
Some lived here, and
then moved there.
We just told people very vague
things that taps into people's
probably badly remembered,
and very distorted,
versions of American history
that would basically suggests
that there should be
some kind of similar kind
of spatial diffusion
process, but now
in your 2D mental map of cities.
So again, there's no claim that
there's any reality to this,
or fine-grained reality.
But we thought it would
sort of roughly correspond
to people's internal
causal generative
models of archeology.
Again, I think it says
something about the way
human intelligence
works that none of us
are archaeologists, probably,
but we still have these ideas.
And it turned out that, here,
a spatially structured model
actually works a lot better.
Again, it shouldn't
be surprising.
It's just showing that actually,
the way-- the judgments
people make when they're making
inferences from a few examples,
just like you saw
with the predicting
the everyday events,
but now in the much more
interestingly
structured domain, is
sensitive to the different kinds
of environmental statistics.
There it was different power
laws versus Gaussian's of cake
bake-- or of movie grosses
versus lifetimes or something.
Here it's other stuff.
It's more interestingly
structured kinds of knowledge.
But you see the same
kind of picture.
And we thought that
was interesting,
and again, suggests
some of the ways
that we are starting to
put these tools together,
putting together probabilistic
generative models
with some kind of interestingly
structured knowledge.
Now, again, as you
saw from Surya,
and as Jay McClellan and
Tim Rogers worked on,
you can try to capture
a lot of this stuff
with neural networks.
The neat thing about the neural
networks that these guys have
worked on is that exactly
the same neural network can
capture this kind
of thing, and it
can capture this kind of thing.
So you can train the very
same hidden multilayer neural
network with one matrix
of object and features.
And the very same
neural network can
predict the tree-structured
patterns for animals
and their properties, as well
as the spatially-structured
patterns for Native American
artifacts and their cities.
The catch is that it doesn't
do either of them that well.
It doesn't do as well as the
tree-structured models do
for peop--
when I say either, it
doesn't do that well, I
mean, in capturing
people's judgments.
It doesn't do as well as the
best tree-structured models do
for people's concepts of
animals and their properties.
And it doesn't do as well as
the best spacial structures.
But again, it's in the same
spirit as the DeepMind networks
for playing lots of Atari games.
The idea there is to have
the same network solve
all these different tasks.
And in some sense, I
think that's a good idea.
I just think that the
architecture should
have a more flexible structure.
So we would also
say, in some sense,
the same architecture is solving
all these different tasks.
It's just that this
is one setting of it.
And this is another
setting of it.
And where they differ is
in the kind of structure
that-- well, they
differ in the fact
that they explicitly represent
structure in the world.
And they explicitly represent
different kinds of structure.
that different kinds
of structure are appropriate
to different kinds of domains
in the world and our intuitions
about the causal processes that
are at work producing the data.
And I think that,
again, that's sort
of the difference between
the pattern classification
and the understanding
or explaining
view of intelligence.
The explanations, of course,
go a lot beyond different ways
that similarity
can be structured.
So one of the kind
of nice things-- oh,
and I guess another--
two other points beyond that.
One is that to get
the neural networks
to do that, you have to train
them with a lot of data.
Remember, Surya, as Tommy
pushed him on in that talk,
Surya was very
concerned with modeling
the dynamics of learning in the
sense of the optimization time
course, how the weights
change over time.
But he was usually
looking at infinite data.
So he was assuming that
you had, effectively,
an infinite number of columns
of any of these matrices.
So you could perfectly
compute the statistics.
And another important
thing about the difference
being the neural network models
and the ones I was showing you
is that, suppose you want
to train the model, not
on an infinite matrix,
but on a small finite one,
and maybe one with missing data.
It's a lot harder to get
the-- the neural network will
do a much poorer job capturing
the structure than these more
structured models.
And again, in a way
that's familiar with--
have you guys talked about
bias-variance dilemma?
So it's that same kind
of idea that you probably
heard about from Lorenzo.
Was it Lorenzo or one
of the machin learni--
OK.
So it's that same kind
of idea, but now applying
in this interesting case
of structured estimation
of generative models
for the world,
that if you have relatively
little data, and sparse data,
then having a more
structured inductive bi--
having the inductive bias that
comes from a more structured
representation is going to
be much more valuable when
you have sparse and noisy data.
The key-- and again, this is
something that Charles and I
were really interested
in-- is we wanted to--
like the DeepMind people,
like the connectionists,
we wanted to build general
purpose semantic cognition,
wanted to build general purpose
learning and reasoning systems.
And we wanted to
somehow figure out
how you could have the best of
both worlds, how you could have
a system that relatively
quickly could come
to get the right kind of strong
constraint-inductive bias
in some domain, and a different
one for a different domain,
yet could learn
in a flexible way
to capture the different
structure in different domains.
More on that in a little bit.
But the other thing I
wanted to talk about here
is just ways in which
our mental models,
our causal and
compositional ones,
go beyond just similarity.
I guess, since time
is short-- well,
I was planning to go through
this relatively quickly.
But anyway, mostly I'll
just gesture towards this.
And if you're
interested, you could
read the papers that
Charles has, or his thesis.
But here, there's a long
history of asking people
to make these kind of
judgments, in which
the basis for the judgment
isn't something like similarity,
but some other kind
of causal reasoning.
So for example, consider
these things here.
Poodles can bite through wire,
therefore German shepherds
can bite through wire.
Is that a strong
argument or weak?
Compare that with, dobermans
can bite through wire, therefore
German shepherds can
bite through wire.
So how many people think that
the top argument is a stronger
one?
How many people think the
bottom line is a stronger one?
So that's typical.
About twice as many
people prefer the top one.
Because intuitively--
do I have a little thing
that will appear?
Intuitively, anyone want to
explain why you thought so?
AUDIENCE: Poodles
are really small.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Poodles
are small or weak.
Yes.
And German shepherds
are big and strong.
And what about dobermans?
AUDIENCE: They're just as
big as German shepherds.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
That's right.
So they're more similar
to German shepherds,
because they're
both big and strong.
But notice that something very
different is going on here.
It's not about similarity.
It's sort of anti-similarity.
But it's not just
anti-similarity.
Suppose I said, German
shepherds can bite through wire,
therefore poodles can
bite through wire.
Is that a good argument?
AUDIENCE: No.
It's an argument against.
JOSH TENENBAUM: No.
It's sort of a terrible
argument, right?
So there's some kind of
asymmetric dimensional
reasoning going on.
Or similarly, if I said,
which of these seems better
intuitively; Salmon
carry some bacteria,
therefore grizzly bears
are likely to carry it,
versus grizzly bears
carry this, therefore
salmon are likely to carry it.
How many people say salmon,
therefore grizzly bears?
How many people say grizzly
bears, therefore salmon?
How do you know?
Those who-- yeah, you're right.
I mean, you're right in
that's what people say.
I don't know if it's right.
Again, I made it up.
But why did you say that,
those of you who said salmon?
AUDIENCE: Bears eat salmon.
JOSH TENENBAUM:
Bears eat salmon.
Yeah.
So assuming that's true,
so we're told or see on TV,
then yeah.
So anyway, these are
these different kinds
of things that are going on.
And to cut to the
chase, what we showed
is that you could capture these
different patterns of reasoning
with, again, the same kind
of thing, but different.
It's also a hierarchical
generative model.
It also has, the key
level of the hierarchy
is some kind of directed
graphical structure
that generates distribution
on observable properties.
But it's a fundamentally
different kind of structure.
It's not just a tree or a space.
It might be a
different kind of graph
and a different kind of process.
So to be a little bit
more technical, the things
I showed you with the tree
and the low-dimensional space,
they had a different
geometry to the graph,
but the same stochastic
process operating over it.
It was, in both cases,
basically a diffusion process.
Whereas to get the kinds of
reasoning that you saw here,
you need a different
kind of graph.
In one case it's like a chain to
capture a dimension of strength
or size, say.
In the other case, it's
some kind of food web thing.
It's not a tree.
It's that kind of
directed network.
But you also need a
different process.
So the ways-- the kind
of probability model
to find that out is different.
And it's easy to see on the--
for example-- on the reasoning
with these threshold things,
like the strength
properties, if you
compare a 1D chain with
just symmetric diffusion,
you get a much
worse fit people's
judgments than if you'd used
what we called this drift
threshold thing, which is
basically a way of saying,
OK, I don't know.
There's some mapping
from strength to being
able to bite through wire.
I don't know exactly what it is.
But the higher up
you go on one, it's
probably more likely
that you can bite--
that you can do the other.
So that provides a wonderful
model of people's judgments
on these kind of tasks.
But that sort of
diffusion process,
like if it was like mutation
in biology, then that
would provide a very bad model.
That's the second row here.
Similarly, this sort of directed
kind of noisy transmission
process on a food web does a
great way of modeling people's
judgments about
diseases, but not
a very good way of
modeling people's judgments
about these
biological properties.
But the tree models
you saw before that
do a great job of
modeling people's
judgments about the
properties of animals,
they do a lousy job of modeling
these disease judgments.
So we have this picture
emerging that, at the time,
was very satisfying to us.
That, hey, we can take
this domain of, say,
animals and their properties,
or the various things we
can reason about, and there's
a lot of different ways
we can reason about
just this one domain.
And by building these
structured probabilistic models
with different kinds
of graphs structures
that capture different
kinds of causal processes,
we could really describe
a lot of different kinds
of reasoning.
And we saw this
as part of a theme
that a lot of other
people were working on.
So this is-- I
mentioned this before,
but now I'm just sort of
throwing it all out there.
A lot of people at
the time-- again,
this is maybe somewhere
between 5 to 10 years ago--
more like six or
seven years ago--
we're extremely interested
in this general view
of common sense reasoning
and semantic cognition
by basically taking big
matrices and boiling them
down to some kind
of graph structure.
In some form, that's what
Tom Mitchell was doing,
not just in the talk
you saw, but remember,
he said there's this
other stuff he does--
this thing called NELL, the
Never Ending Language Learner.
I'm showing a little
glimpse of that
up there from a New York Times
piece on it in the upper right.
In some ways, in a sort of
at least more implicit way,
it's what the neural networks
that Jay McClelland, Tim
Rogers, Surya were
talking about do.
And we thought-- you
know, we had good reason
to think that our
approach was more
like what people were doing
than some of these others.
But I then came to see-- and
this was around the time when
CBMM was actually
getting started--
that none of these
were going to work.
Like the whole thing was
just not going to work.
Liz was one of the main people
who convinced me of this.
But you could just
read the New York Times
article on Tom Mitchell's piece,
and you can see what's missing.
So there's Tom, remember.
This was an article from 2010.
Just to set the chronology
right, that was right around--
a little bit after Charles had
finished all that nice work
I showed you, which again,
I still think is valuable.
I think it is
capturing something
about what's going on.
It was very appealing to
people, like at Google,
because these knowledge graphs
are very much like the way,
around the same time,
Google was starting
to try to put more
semantics into web search--
again, connected to the
work that Tom was doing.
And there was this nice
article in the New York
Times talking about how they
built their system by reading
the web.
But the best part
of it was describing
one of the mistakes
their system made.
So let me just show this to you.
About knowledge that's
obvious to a person,
but not to a
computer-- again, it's
Tom Mitchell himself
describing this.
And the challenge of, that's
where NELL has to be headed,
is how to make the things
that are obvious to people
obvious to computers.
He gives this
example of a bug that
happened in NELL's early life.
The research team noticed that--
oh, let's skip down there.
So, a particular example--
when Dr. Mitchell scanned the
baked goods category recently,
he noticed a clear pattern.
NELL was at first
quite accurate, easily
identifying all kinds of pies,
breads, cakes, and cookies
as baked goods.
But things went awry after
NELL's noun phrase classifier
decided internet cookies
was a baked good.
NELL had read the sentence "I
deleted my internet cookies."
And again, think of
that as, it's kind
of like a simple proposition.
It's like, OK.
But the way it parses
that is cookies
are things that can be
deleted, the same way you can
say horses have T9 hormones.
It's basically just a matrix.
And the concept is
internet cookies.
And then there's the
property of can be deleted,
or something like that.
And it knows something about
natural language processing.
So it can see--
and it's trying
to be intelligent.
Oh, internet cookies.
Well, maybe like chocolate
chip cookies and oatmeal raisin
cookies, those were
a kind of cookies.
Basically, that's what it did.
Or no, actually
did the opposite.
[LAUGHS]
It said-- when it read
"I deleted my files,"
it decided files was
probably a baked good, too.
Well, first it decided internet
cookies was a baked good,
like those other cookies.
And then it decided that
files were a baked goods.
And it started this whole
avalanche of mistakes,
Dr. Mitchell said.
He corrected the
internet cookies error
and restarted NELL's
bakery education.
[LAUGHS] I mean, like, OK.
Now rerun without that problem.
So the point, the lesson
Tom draws from this,
and that the
article talks about,
is, oh, well, we still
need some assistance.
We have to go back and,
by hand, set these things.
But the key thing
is that, really--
I think the message
this is telling
us is no human child would
ever make this mistake.
Human children
learn in this way.
They don't need this
kind of assistance.
It's true that, as Tom
says, you and I don't
learn in isolation either.
So, all of the things
we've been talking about,
about learning from prior
knowledge and so on, are true.
But there's a basic kind
of common sense thing
that this is missing,
which is that at the time
a child is learning
anything about--
by the time a child is learning
anything about computers,
and files, and so on, they
understand well before that,
like back in early infancy, from
say, work that Liz has done,
and many others, that cookies,
in the sense of baked goods,
are a physical object, a kind
of food, a thing you eat.
Files, email-- not
a physical object.
And there's all sorts
of interesting stuff
to understand about how kids
learn that a book can be both
a no-- a novel is both
a story and it's also
a physical object, and
so a lot of that stuff.
But there's a basic
common sense understanding
of the world as consisting
of physical objects,
and for example,
agents and their goals.
You heard a little bit
about this from us,
from me and Tomer,
on the first day.
And that's where I
want to turn to next.
And this is just one of many
examples that we realized,
as cool as this system is, as
great as all this stuff is,
just trying to approach semantic
knowledge and common sense
reasoning as some kind
of big matrix completion
without a much more fundamental
grasp of the ways in which
the world is real
to a human mind,
well before they're learning
anything about language
or any of this
higher level stuff,
it was just not going
to work, in the same way
that I think if you want to
build a system that learns
to play a video game,
even remotely like the way
a human does,
there's a lot of more basic
stuff you have to build on.
And it's the same basic
stuff, I would argue.
A cool thing about
Atari video games
is that, even though they
were very low resolution,
very low-bit color displays,
with very big pixels, what
makes your ability to
learn that game work is
the same kind of thing that
makes the ability, even as
a young child, to not
make this mistake.
And it's the kind of
thing that Liz and people
in her field of
developmental psychology--
in particular, infant research--
have been studying really
excitingly for a
couple of decades.
That, I think, is as
transformative for the topic
of intelligence in brains,
minds, and machines
as anything.
So that's what
motivated the work we've
been doing in the last few
years and the main work we're
trying to do in the center.
And it also goes hand-in-hand
with the ways in which
we've realized that we have
to take what we've learned how
to do with building problematic
models over interesting
symbolically-structured
representations
and so on, but move way
beyond what you could call--
I mean, we need better,
even more interesting,
symbolic representations.
In particular, we need
to move beyond graphs
and stochastic processes
defined over graphs to programs.
So that's where the
probabilistic programs
come back into the mix.
So again, you already saw this.
And I'm trying to
close the loop back
to what we're doing in CBMM.
I've given you
about 10 to 15 years
of background in our field
of how we got to this, why
we think this is
interesting and important,
and why we think we need to--
why we've developed a
certain toolkit of ideas,
and why we think we needed
to keep extending it.
And I think, as you saw
before, and as you'll see,
this also, in some ways--
I think we're getting more and
more to the interesting part
of common sense.
But in another way, we're
getting back to the problems
I started off with
and what a lot
of other people at
this summer school
have an interest
in, which is things
like much more basic aspects
of visual perception.
I think the heart of real
intelligence and common sense
reasoning that
we're talking about
is directly connected to vision
and other sense modalities,
and how we get around in the
world and plan our actions,
and the very basic
kinds of goal social
understandings that you
saw in those little videos
of the red and blue
ball, or that you
see if you're trying to do
action recognition and action
understanding.
So in some sense, it's
gotten more cognitive.
But it's also, by getting to
the root of our common sense
knowledge, it makes better
contact with vision,
with neuroscience research.
And so I think it's a
super exciting development
in what we're doing for
the larger Brains, Minds,
and Machines agenda.
So again, now we're
saying, OK, let's
try to understand
the way in which--
even these kids
playing with blocks,
the world is real to them.
It's not just a
big matrix of data.
That is a thing in their hands.
And they have an
understanding of what
a thing is before they start
compiling lists of properties.
And they're playing
with somebody else.
That hand is attached to
a person, who has goals.
It's not just a big matrix
of rows and columns.
It's an agent with
goals, and even a mind.
And they understand
those things before they
start to learn a lot of other
things, like words for objects,
and advanced game-playing
behavior, and so on.
And when we want to
talk about learning,
we still are interested
in one-shot learning,
or very rapid learning
from a few examples.
And we're still interested
in how prior knowledge guides
that, and how that
knowledge can be built.
But we want to do
it in this context.
We want to study in
the context of, say,
how you learn how magnets
work, or how you learn
how a touchscreen device
works-- really interesting kinds
of grounded physical causes.
So this is what we
have, or what I've come
to call the common sense core.
Liz, are you going to talk
about core knowledge at all?
so there's a phrase
that Liz likes
to use called core knowledge.
And this is definitely
meant to evoke that.
And it's inspired by it.
I guess I changed
it a little bit,
because I wanted it
to mean something
a little bit different.
And I think, again, to
anticipate a little bit,
the main difference is--
I don't know.
What's the main difference?
The main difference is
that, in the same way
that lots of people look
at me and say, oh, he's
the Bayesian guy, lots
of people look at Liz
and say, oh, she's the
nativist gal or something.
And it's true that, compared
to a lot of other people,
I tend to be more
interested, and have
done more work
prominently associated
with Bayesian inference.
But by no means do I think
that's the whole story.
And part of what I tried to show
you, and will keep showing you,
is ways in which
that's only really
the beginning of the story.
And Liz is prominently
associated,
and you'll see some of this,
with really fascinating
discoveries that key high
level concepts, key kinds
of real knowledge, are
present, in some sense,
as early as you can look,
and in some form, I think,
very plausibly, have to be
due to some kind of innately
unfolding genetic program that
builds a mind the same way it
builds a brain.
But just as we'll
hear from her, that's,
in some ways, only the
beginning, or only one part
of a much richer,
more interesting story
that she's been developing.
But for that, among
other reasons,
I'm calling it a
little different.
And I'm trying to emphasize the
connection to what people in AI
call common sense reasoning.
Because I really do think this
is the heart of common sense.
It's this intuitive physics
and intuitive psychology.
So again, you saw us already
give an intro to this.
Maybe what I'll just do is
show you a little bit more
of the-- well, are you going
to talk about the stuff at all?
LIZ SPELKE: I guess.
Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Well, OK.
So this is work-- some of
this is based on Liz's work.
Some of this is based
on Rene Baillargeon,
a close colleague of hers, and
many other people out there.
And I wasn't really going
to go into the details.
And maybe, Liz, we can decide
whether you want to do this
or not.
But what they've shown
is that, even prior
to the time when kids are
learning words for objects,
all of this stuff with infants,
two months, four months, eight
months--
at this age, kids have, at
best, some vague statistical
associations of words
to kinds of objects.
But they already
have a great deal
of much more abstract
understanding
of physical objects.
So I won't-- maybe I should
not go into the details of it.
But you saw it in that nice
video of the baby playing
with the cups.
And there's really
interesting, sort
of rough, developmental
timelines.
One of the things we're
trying to figure out in CBMM
is to actually get much,
much clearer picture on this.
But at least if you look across
a bunch of different studies,
sometimes by one lab,
sometimes up by multiple labs,
you see ways in which, say,
going from two months to five
months, or five
months to 12 months,
kids seem to-- their
intuitive physics of objects
is getting a little
bit more sophisticated.
So for example, they
tend to understand--
in some form, they understand
a little bit of how collisions
conserve momentum, a little bit,
by five months or six months--
according to one of
Baillargeon's studies--
in the sense that if they
see a ball roll down a ramp
and hit another one,
and the second one goes
a certain distance, if
a bigger object comes,
they're not too surprised
if this one goes farther.
But if a little object hits
it, then they are surprised.
So they expect a bigger
object to be able to move it
more than a little object.
But a two-month-old
doesn't understand that.
Although a two-month-old does
understand-- this is, again,
from Liz's work--
that if an object is
colluded by a screen,
it hasn't disappeared,
and that if an object
is rolling towards a wall,
and that wall looks solid,
that the object can't go through
it, and that if it somehow--
when the screen is removed,
as you see on the upper left--
appears on the other side
of the screen, that's
very surprising to them.
I think-- I'm sure what Liz will
talk about, among other things,
are the methods they use, the
looking time methods to reveal
this.
And I think there's really--
this is one of the two
main insights that I,
and I think our
whole field, needs
to learn from
developmental psychology,
is how much of a basic
understanding of physics
like this is present very early.
And it doesn't
matter whether it's--
in some sense, it doesn't
matter for the points
I want to make here, how much
or in what way this is innate,
or how the genetics and
the experience interact.
I mean, that does matter.
And that, that's something
we want to understand,
and we are hoping
to try to understand
in the hopefully
not-too-distant future.
But for the purpose
of understanding
what is the heart
of common sense,
how are we going to build
these causal, compositional,
generative models to
really get at intelligence,
the main thing is that it should
be about this kind of stuff.
That's the main focus.
And then the other big insight
from developmental psychology,
which has to do with
how we build this stuff,
is this idea sometimes called
the child as scientist.
The basic idea is that, just
as this early commonsense
knowledge is something
like a scientific theory,
something like a good scientific
theory, the way Newton's laws
are a better scientific
theory than Kepler's laws
because of how they capture the
causal structure of the world
in a compositional way.
That's another
way to sum up what
I'm trying to say about
children's early knowledge.
But also, the way children build
their knowledge is something
like the way scientists
build their knowledge, which
is, well, they do
experiments, of course.
We normally call that play.
That's one of Laura's
Schulz's big ideas.
But it's not just
about the experiments.
I mean, Newton didn't
really do any experiments.
He just thought.
And that's another thing you'll
hear from Laura, and also
from Tomer, is that a lot
of children's learning
looks less like, say, stochastic
gradient descent, and more
like scratching your head
and trying to make sense of,
well, that's really funny.
Why does this happen here?
Why does that happen over there?
Or how can I explain
what seemed to be
diverse patterns of phenomena
with some common underlying
principles, and making
analogies between things,
and then trying out, oh,
well, if that's right,
then it would make
this prediction.
And the kid doesn't have to
be conscious of that the way
scientists maybe are.
That process of coming
up with theories
and considering variations,
trying them out,
seeing what kinds of new
experiences you can create
for yourself--
call them an
experiment, or call them
just a game, or
playing with a toy,
but that dynamic is the real
heart of how children learn
and build the knowledge
from the early stages
to what we come
to have as adults.
Those two insights of what we
start with and how we grow,
I think, are hugely powerful
and hugely important
for anything we want to do in
capturing-- making machines
that learn like
humans, or making
computational models that
really get at the heart of how
we come to be smart.